[Music]
Representative Keith Ellison a Minnesota
Democrat and Deputy chair of the
Democratic National Committee recently
wrote to amazon.com's Jeff Bezos
demanding that he drop from sale at
Amazon material that the Southern
Poverty Law Center dislikes yes it has
come to this Ellison's letter to Bezos
focuses on an alleged neo-nazis material
being sold at Amazon and published on
Amazon's self-publishing platform but
Ellison makes more sweeping statements
particularly his opening Gambit I am
writing to you with my concerns about
the amount of money Amazon has made from
the sale of literature and music
published by entities identified as hate
groups by the Southern Poverty Law
Center
splc clearly Ellison wants Amazon which
has with Barnes & Noble a virtual
monopoly on Book Sales in the US to stop
selling books by people designated as
hate groups by the Southern Poverty Law
Center like the establishment media
Ellison assumes that the splc is a
reliable unbiased Arbiter of what is and
isn't a hate group the splc's hard-left
bias and determination to destroy
legitimate conservative groups by
lumping them in with neo-nazis and white
supremacists is nowhere recognized the
splc has for a considerable period
enjoyed unquestioned magisterial
Authority in the establishment meeting
but its credibility took a serious hit
recently when it had to pay over $3
million to a liberal Muslim it had
smeared as an anti-muslim extremist
Ellison however takes it for granted
that the splc is reliable and assumes
that Bezos does as well and he's likely
right about that the far-left Bezos
almost certainly agrees with Ellison
that the splc is a reliable Authority
and so it is entirely possible that he
will comply with Ellison's demands and
Purge Amazon of all material matal by
people that the splc has smeared and
defamed among the questions Ellison asks
Bezos is this will Amazon stop
publishing physical and digital
materials from splc identified hate
groups in the next 3 months given
Amazon's dominance of the book Market
Amazon's compliance to this demand would
be a serious blow to the freedom of
speech as the splc is making an allout
attempt to delegitimize the full
spectrum of opinion that descents from
the leftist agenda on Islam immigration
social issues and more if Amazon drops
splc designated hate material there
should ensue a national discussion about
whether the splc is really a reliable
Authority and whether only one Viewpoint
should be allowed in the Public Square
if not this will be just another nail in
the coffin of the freedom of speech in
the US Ellison meanwhile has spoken at a
Convention of the Islamic Society of
North America yet isna has actually
admitted its ties to Hamas which Styles
itself the Palestinian arm of the Muslim
Brotherhood the justice department
actually classified the Islamic Society
of North America among entities who are
and or were members of the US Muslim
Brotherhood and it gets worse in 2008
Ellison accepted
$3,350 from the Muslim American society
to go on a pilgrimage to Mecca the
Muslim American society is a Muslim
Brotherhood organization in recent years
the us Brotherhood operated under the
name Muslim American society according
to documents and interviews one of the
nation's most major Islamic groups it
was incorporated in Illinois in 1993
after a contentious debate among
Brotherhood members that's from the
Chicago Tribune in 2004 in an article
that is now carried on the Muslim
brotherhood's English language website
Ian web also the Hamas link Council on
American Islamic relations care raised
large amounts of money for Ellison's
first camp pain and he has spoken at
numerous Care events yet care is an
unindicted co-conspirator in a Hamas
Terror funding case so named by the
justice department care officials have
repeatedly refused to denounce Hamas and
his Bala as terrorist groups will the
freedom of speech be done in by this man
while the answer to that question is
playing out strike a blow for the
freedom of thought get my new book the
history of jihad from Muhammad to Isis
from Amazon while you still can it tells
truths about Islam and Jihad that Keith
Ellison and the splc don't want you to
know I'm Robert Spencer a showman fellow
for the David Hart's Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the center for
security policy
[Music]